where everybody what's going on welcome
to Monday man they were very excited we
got Mark Ellis in the house from schmoes
know youtube.com slash modes movie
review show which is hilarious and also
really Hershkovitz over here howdy
Beth Morosky in the chat room Jason
O'Malley on the ones and twos Hey today
we're very excited because we're playing
an old school game bond Goldeneye for
the n64 I went at the game due to North
Hollywood and got extra controllers for
this this is real n64 this is not like
the Xbox 360 there isn't I'm looking at
an actual Nintendo 64 console that's
right uh welcome by Roy Makaay go lover
26 there you go I just said your name so
we're gonna play some BOTS now I haven't
fired this game up you were saying in
college you should get your ass oh no I
got a bad experience in this game
because my freshman year at college
everybody grew up playing in 64 my mom
was like hey you get a Sega Genesis
that's good enough for you I've never
made the upgrade to the 64 console so in
the common room everybody's playing bond
and you want to be cool you want to fit
in is the guy that you look for when
you're playing Goldeneye because you can
shoot me and get easy points because I
have no idea what the hell I'm doing to
this game
Shmuel Ville knows me as the world's
greatest game boy Tetris player oh when
I playing Game Boy temperature oh no
world of 64-bit graphics no way so which
should we started you guys wanted you
five minutes you want to do five points
when you want to do a little warm-up I'm
gonna get warm yeah I played this all
right rusty
we'll start with slappers only start
with automatics sure these do automatic
you'd pick our character see remember
this remember this I don't want to be
Sean Bean cuz he dies in everything
that's right exactly we just want to be
our job or it's I just want to be our
job flat fireboard will play slappers
only when we get a little used to the
guy oh this guy I would be the voodoo
guy Baron Samedi zombie I'm gonna be
Michigan Oh Captain Kirk of 91 says
greetings for schmoeville huh what's up
schmoeville thanks for supporting me I
will
let you down but talk about alright here
we go you guys ready oh my god
oh man I'm nervous okay can I only throw
the hat once I I would love multiple hi
I'm upper left
I'm upper left where are you guys there
we go I'm ready right I'm a bottom-line
know what
all right the trigger does the karate
chop okay Oh
oh my god Jesus Chris graphics are crazy
how this game works I got a gun and I
think the right bumper aims and then the
trigger shoots this music final boring
yeah okay yeah oh dude this is bringing
back all kinds of crazy memories all
right look up no odd job you cheater
fawful says okay I've got my I've got
finally got my hand technique together
yeah this is confusing okay now I
remember yeah there's only one oh wait
there's only I don't know how to fire
that's me all right
there's only one uh there's only one
stick on this controller that's right
yeah I'm I'm used to multiple nipples on
my controller yeah you want multiple
nips asmik Jogia over to 69 can attest
to looks fine I wasn't blessed with a
gun either
I found one oh what's that I feel like
I'm getting shot at I have ammo and no
go yeah I'm killing somebody oh boy oh
oh this is like reversed I need a gun
there's what whoever I'm shooting at
there's a gun really close to you okay
now I'm gonna go oh you guys so I can
look for a gun and be murdered that
wasn't good now I got a club what is
that Oh what is that
don't be going down shot yeah oh my god
I have smellman is toast I love when you
kill somebody cuz did it I have so much
ammo and no good zombie nation I was
always told to play jaws for a handicap
oh because jaws is easier to hit cuz
he's bigger oh wait yeah that sounds
like that sounds fair to me he's got
those metal teeth he's got to run around
with
oh whoa I got a pistol here oh man oh I
got a bunch of guns more I got to see
the one stick thing is very weird yeah
I'm struggling i I'm selling it you down
with my karate Trev here we go I've got
a club this is like playing on this
prize says I'm just running over
anything else ha I'm armed
I have ammo now you guys I feel good I
feel good about everything that's
happening guys I can't find anybody I
know
it's about it I'm just looking for some
friends the kid Scarlet's Ajax thank you
oh whoa wait a minute whoa whoa
I love the bullet holes in the wall
somebody upstairs don't think I'm not
coming for you I'm in third place right
now that might be the best place like I
stay in how do I reload I can't wait no
come out come out wherever you are I see
you I see you wait
oh must aim no yeah come on hey come on
over here yeah okay I'm going down this
is how I be a real war by just standing
shoot we're murdering whoever's I just
want to say I used to play this game a
ton and I was terrible at it then - yeah
I think it might be a team-up situation
against there in here and I say you
can't do two against one by the way
maybe the next time you think we just
did
bring it on look at the mat okay here we
go
what's up a red sky by the way where are
we like Mars
I know it's Russia I get it it's like a
metaphor
I see what they did here well if you
want to reintroduce the people some
people just joined
yeah everybody this is uh this is Mark
Ellis from schmoes nose up gang go see
is uh because he's amazing
move your review show at youtube.com
slash Moe's no as i murder him
roadie Hershkovitz I'm he's being
murdered he's right there and I can't
shoot what's the button to show Morosky
are the trigger I just found a whole new
I just died again but now I found out
not too late we got for the very first
time I think I might be crouching zombie
nation
yes sings like a catcher yeah how do you
how do you crowd I'm stuck in a crouch
how are you crouching boy buddy no idea
okay I'm off to a rocky start but I'm
very oh yes stray fingers yes straight
fingers kid oh hey there I'm a job
nothing pretty quick so sorry gonna love
that
fill up that glass come on out here ah
ja ah you little bastard ah take that
you little bastard alright I think why
don't we play to you ten verses right
now gun I'm looking for a guns if you
find one split it with me okay ah I'm in
it I'm in some sort of ventilation shaft
I have a gun
this feels like die hard I don't have
any weapons I'm a little nervous
you're jumping who's the red dot the red
dot e the red dot is is probably
nee-sama
so I need to kill the blue dot we're
killing the blue dot yeah you have to
restart again i mouse
open this door you're trying to kill the
blue dye there we go
Oh God I'm chopping here hello I have a
gun why am i chopping get out of here Oh
God she's never gone where'd he go I got
a gun all right
I need to somehow get by all right
open this door B thank you I'm just I'm
just taking a poop come on bleh oh I
should not get cocky
hey ah good to see you pal Oh what's up
yeah all right I'm going in is this the
door get back here get back here will
you come back oh no I got a gun oh Jesus
there's a sty hard-driving game
oh god everybody's out hit somebody okay
honey I'm right behind you ah this
auto-aim apron
Jesus God I'm gonna slap you
No stop slapping now
ah oh no I got killed way to go way to
give it team red baby we did it Oh take
it oh god oh man here we go all right
well I've died once
now I'm gonna some sort of shaft where
am I
feels like they always throw you out in
the shaft
wait you feel like that Oh God oh that's
me that's my husband all right
whoo oh he's this way
I'm looking for my shaft [ __ ] never
to find me I'm just talking about shaft
Aaron lover to my mom hi this is Aaron
[Music]
black clearly you bought your son an n64
it's something yes exactly
my mom did hook me up with video games
so thanks for that mom mom all these
murders are dedicated to you we're
taking down team red oh you son of a
[ __ ] who's right near me body armor
nope nope I'm out of here later get back
here you will not run away for now boy
Jesus God that gun is really scary I'm
sorry my gun scares you ran up the rent
of the stairs
I gotta get a gun that would probably
help oh god one minute left I have one
minute left cause we're playing a time
Brown oh yeah I forgot about that
dad did you go it's just me job forget
amalgam of every great Bond villain ah I
see you I see you
oh my god please reload your gun Jesus
God wait yeah where is he I gotta go in
hand to hand comes for you Bob that does
for you where is he at I'm just going I
have no gun hashtag mom kill hey kill it
for BA
here we go here we go here we go just
need one working
oh there we go
needing to gun yeah there we go oh
really I really knew I was ready to
shoot I was dying maybe you know what
maybe we should try maybe we should try
rocket lunch okay that might help you
guys hello I was the man of rocket
launchers I was like I was like Elway
throwing a vortex
I could I could crush people with rocket
launchers in this game I don't know if
it's gonna pay off but try try Oh - we
love this game too
hashtag mom kill I'm feeling you there
hit start hit start everybody here we
are
judi dench this gamer should dlc this is
way before
alright let's go ah where's a good place
to shoot rockets I thought you know I
feel the bunker there was one I think
you know what they tell us like two
minute closer quarters temple rockets
yeah
temple Rock it's also pistols caves was
uh was one I would always do lasers
laser don't try lasers I don't know that
sounds that sounds spacious thuds
intense you might want to keep the
characters even whichever Carol what's
the thing we're with the least amount of
bathing I mean I think rocket is a
rocket is I think rockets is see
somebody in the general vicinity sure to
rock and Adam yeah roll the dice we're
still two on one right I was still
two-on-one date okay we're gonna go two
on one until further let's go Java cheat
because he's shorter Oh
shorter so it's harder to hit but not
for me temple remotes mines will play
next time fireborn remote mines will
play next time alright we are looking
for some rockets well somebody's got a
rocket launcher oh oh oh I have a tiny
gun and everybody else has rockets oh so
there are other guns in this oh yeah I
got a Soviet yes yeah guys this is
called duty 9 yeah it's a throwback this
is called a duty and it's throwback
uniform
yeah in its throwback ebook all right I
get too close
can you still rock at me oh yeah oh
there's only one rocket I gotta be
kidding me
only one rocket at this Wow I got a club
just a son of a [ __ ]
yeah rogue job more like dead job wait
all right madam well let's kill him good
god man I shot you like a thousand times
odd-job still hanging in there you short
bastard yes hashtag mob kill it for you
mom I shall avenge you odd-job exactly
marked us live about your show my show
is a movie review show you can subscribe
to on YouTube and we get all the latest
movie reviews out our thing is you never
pay to see a bad movie again no but yes
a lot of money got him a lot of wants to
pay for ticket to see a movie not your
large bucket of popcorn we wanted to be
worth your while that's all that's movie
in the summer you see so far who
Jurassic world's up there oh really
Ventris is up there Mad Max is up Max
yeah Mad Max was 200 yeah this is Matt
backside pillock would be good at this
game yeah I feel like Charlize Theron
scared to be better but she only has one
hand so I don't know that's true that's
a good point I would help her they both
be kicking my eyes to this game in in
dinosaur terms y'all are like the
indominus rex and i'm like one of those
cute little raptors it screams oh I'm
telling you man I'm coming up on your
job how did you first start doing your
movie review show how did you decide for
movie we're like man working in an
office songs let's do something else
that it does we start on YouTube in 2009
2010 some around there wow
we were both comics at the time and how
did you guys meet each other still a
comic we met doing stand-up oh that's
awesome
sorry I Java shot at you that's that's
whatever does the interviews he gets in
this old man Barbara Walters yeah that's
what and then all of a sudden bang
you're dead that's me
yeah they don't Barbara Walters we
really just sort of colonize this little
community we call schmoeville
which a lot of you guys are very let
down by my gameplay right now but it's
still it's a great place to either be a
part of so we love talking to come on
out to the death room sweet death fuels
come on out to the death room come on
out to the death room where it's
somebody close oh maybe you're on the
lower level I think that's what you feel
like when you see something and it's
terrible you have to give it some sort
of yeah redeeming value like you still
have to fluff it a little all right okay
just going this was a steaming pile of
oh [ __ ] on if you give us something like
Hot Pursuit you weren't gonna [ __ ] on it
I actually took it in the middle Havasu
and that was the best part of that that
was the best that was much better than
anything I saw on screen here we come on
oh yeah
I don't know where somebody went
somewhere I'm in a dark top
hey guys why are you
I'm just looking for people to play with
[Music]
something's really good at dodging me
I'm shooting with the legs that's what I
do hit you once
odd oh okay we'll work on that
did mom kill you mom I love you mom
hashtag mom kill here we go oh this
rocket
oh this rocket just wants to get up on
somebody's face what I know there you
are there we go what are what now what
do you look for in a movie what's it
like what it is it do you know every
genre you like I go to the movies to
have a great time I love all genres
review everything and by the way I now
have the rocket launcher let's see how
this goes I think this is gonna go great
yeah I mean you know you see a lot of
blockbusters then all of a sudden it's
like man I'm really tired of these
things I want to see something oh boy oh
boy that was very well shot okay that
one wasn't as much I'm dead we got him
dad waited it out we are invincible
waiting it out Jace maybe not yeah next
week maybe old battlefronts god froma be
good ah Star Wars Battlefront wow that
looks really whole thank you for sharing
that with it very exciting I played a
little bit of that at e3 last week and
it was really fun we were in store with
celebration they showed the trailer for
that for the first time and people are
losing their mom yeah yeah start
celebration was nothing but great
trailers and it was oh my god star was
just so cool
hey so wait what's your opinion as a
professional movie reviewer done like
Jar Jar and the new word wait a minute
no you're messing me all up on the
prequels I'm not a huge fan of the
prequel they each one has redeeming
quality but Jar Jar is not one of them
see here's the thing I do a really
really hard thing I see a ton of movies
yeah I do not watch trailers and you
never letting apart that my little
flying game thing about if I know I'm
going to see a movie especially anything
sci-fi or fantasy you don't want to know
anything I don't want to see allow for
ream of it okay I went to see Jurassic
world I watched the ant-man trailer up
until he got in the suit once he got in
the suit no discipline I why I didn't
know that the Hulk was in the new
Avenger movie until I went to saw it and
they introduced Bruce Banner I'm
dedicated really I have not seen a bit
of the new stories amazing to me
yeah like here's the thing I know I'm
gonna see that movie I want it all at
once I don't want to see how awesome it
is until I'm there watching it right
watch the first trailer so you haven't
seen any of the force awakens not not a
bit oh no all I saw was like one picture
on the cover of a magazine I don't even
look at posters my god I crazy I give
too many shits to to start getting a
taste of all of a pasture hashtag all
this [ __ ] I don't I don't want to know I
don't want to know until I'm there and
that makes things like you about start
talking about our Wars really difficult
right well give way I won't give away
anything all I'll say is that I think
that if you're a huge Star Wars fan you
should watch the trailers because
they're too smart to give away any huge
plot points right and in case the movies
aren't great like the prequels I still
got so emotional watching a each one of
those trailers to so you get a little
bit of new Star Wars stuff and it gets
you excited that's awesome I tried
watching the trailer I cried watching
those receivers
you did I did Allison the reason I do
that is because they give away so much
in the trailer so hearing that it's like
a true teaser right I love the idea I
just kill you I just
hey mom sorry turns mom oh this is great
I killed myself with my owner going gun
screw these rockets I'm going old school
boy that I think I think we've I think
we've awakened a sleeping giant
yeah the play awakens I'm not arguing
that I'm not arguing it's a weird effed
up system and I wish I didn't have to do
it but I do not asking you to agree take
that you communist sob oh I just killed
Aaron twice in a row yeah yeah yeah the
Ellis awaken really glaze what's
happening the whole crowd right now is
chanting all right okay no more Rockets
so we're gonna have to go back to the
old school technique of chopping finally
Aaron killed oh you had that killed
right away but my I've been running
around by my side I think I'm like the
dellavedova of this game like a couple
shots and then I'm gonna come back down
there it's really quick I need some guns
I need to go to the store I got some ham
before you let me just give it to you
real quick oh my god about that rocket
one Wow hey wait what I feel like you
guys laid a trap for me boom I got the
lunar surface another assassin Ellis has
come to play
Ellis has come to play dude now see it's
maybe it we should go offer uh offer
each other again it's for operating I
want to get on a bond game I mean none
of us are playing as bad as Denise
Richards scientist character trait to
Christmas Jones yeah we're we're like
we're like a jinx efox yeah no that's
boss it stings best bond who's the best
buy I think Henry's the best bomb but
those Roger Moore movies are great
there's so much fun to watch oh yes I
eat it ours will get that bet three
kills number though kids that say how
hard this is to play this is that that's
an unimpressed with myself well done
three kills all right we got us a ball
game I love it no kills I think it's
time for pissed
case that can't be right I think that no
kills for me I think what happened is
this I think that I think that you were
they you were buttering him up
you were the appetizer yeah I had this
summer you're the Pippen you're the
Pippen is Jordan exactly the trophy boy
I was getting real cocky there Oh check
the awards okay
oh that's right there's like most
whatever right yeah all right we're
gonna do that I got the make-a-wish rule
is there one that says most time running
around lost by yourself yeah most times
spend writing poetry all right let's try
lasers man you want to do lasers uh
we're mcasterisk for what's the least
complicated math that you could
recommend to us least complicated math
yes please he killed himself for this
skill level is proxy me all right should
we try proximity mines proximity mines I
learned I think where you throw up on
the walls of something they blow up Oh
God okay sure so we try that so that
people just run by and then you run by
all right a little more strategy
involved yeah oh good I'll think my way
here we go tie my proximity mine yeah
yeah caves cage sounds like a place for
proximity race chew on water all all
against each other again I'm sticking
with two of zero kills in the last round
says marina three girls between the two
of us that's all I'm counting yeah
proximity mines luck skill throw it all
out the door turn on paintball statute
not cage case it is whoever said knock
caves caves it is great what people just
chimed in with never the caves here it
is games oh here's one caves it's so
dark okay this is like the cave in the
new Star Wars trailer I'm kidding yeah
how did you guys feel when you saw a
Darth Vader stand up at the end of
Revenge of the Sith and you know pretty
great we are in the cave we are deep in
the caves right now
come on I feel like I'm walking around
in Nicolas Cage's head yeah this is
darkness
yeah it's hi RJ right yay we can't see
we get plagued by my own insanity
exactly cave looks like an ear canal for
the right I remember its level well I
don't I remember I like that like the
Led Zeppelin reference again oh my god
this is like our thinking this was like
cutting-edge to you guys remember that's
like this was soo this elevated doom
this way was the next level of doom and
then you know halo came out in xbox and
blue everything else out of the water
but yeah this is uh right Nexus you're
right you're clearly right on top on the
array no yeah I feel like I'm doing why
oh okay I found tonight
can you approximate I've made some
progress I'm now in the anvil of the ear
you guys remember that with the ear
there's like the anvil stirreth hammer
and the hammer there's a hammer and fall
this is all you kids are gonna remember
class just little bits of crap that you
don't need um where we add a job we're
we're way far away from everybody else
apparently I'm getting farther by the
second there we go they know you got you
got somebody you got somebody coming up
on you I see nothing it is very dark it
is very black how your mood is a player
shifts when you go to a different map
yeah gonna cave and everybody gets
really silent is that I know I know this
isn't a toy down bad ah I miss someone
near me Oh somebody's definitely
shooting at me yeah what is that
and to be honest they should be
Oh Oh shite
get up you basket yeah yeah what
happened proximity mine oh my god
remember the level baby I finally found
my friends and I was like hey guys party
woo come on Blake show yourself to me
okay party I can't aim oh I know I can
taste shut up
right I'm literally firing at the
ceiling but I think the good thing is
you cleared this mind from this corridor
for me yeah yeah no dark in this room I
can't even see the way I came here yeah
oh I got hit with a mine you guys wait
did you die I didn't die though nobody
died I just caught a little
it's not a person at all the arrow in
the world is that a person or just a
shadow is the greatest game ever yeah I
think we think we agree to something way
above our skill set when we said yeah
caves for proximity mines or when we
said sure Goldeneye I do like that it's
not just proximity mines that there are
weapons that you can use it yeah because
you can try to be a strategist or you
can just go around and shoot people
right or you can do neither and if I had
a land mines up in a cave are you a
little fire scarecrow for you bought
this for you everyone no longer take you
to the Olive Garden take us so my mom
does love the other guy oh oh yeah let's
say I got some body armor right before
oh good man maybe you survive one of
those one of mine welcome to my funhouse
uh mark what are some uh now if I'm a
screenwriter what are some traps that
most people writing movies fall into if
you're like if you're writing a movie I
think a lot of times son of a bee sting
[Music]
[Music]
the minds
oh the beautiful mind but a lot of times
screenwriters let the underdog and and
that's and we just see from this that
real life the underdog never wins I
spawn and then I took three steps you
same thing every night I took three
scene I wanna die another day
Ellis yeah this is I dude I'm just
bananas with these Minds right I need
that I need that Bond car that turns in
business
to get the hell out of here my gut looks
very impressive okay now I got a cool
gun and I got some ammo and I'm feeling
good I got a health protein shake - here
we go go into Whole Foods oh now we're
now we're ready to go now I just gotta
find my boys and not walk into a
landmine where are you Oh bleh
no I can't die you can die or you can
die even you oh my god guys come on
oh Jesus
is there an award for most times
shooting a person without killing them
oh man I'm right on Aaron's tail good
answer question yeah yeah what yeah the
biggest trap they fall into is when they
try to inject too much into one movie
like they try to put too much silly
humor in a big action movie like what
Michael Bay does with transformers it's
like we don't need all the humor to a
point we don't even need human beings
and transformers just trust us if we
want the transformers and that's it this
is not good yeah that's true runaway
runaway oh yeah go up there oh you son
of a [ __ ] go up there now I want you to
go up there oh that's true I will say
like and by the same token you ever see
a rain of fire
yeah it's McConaughey yeah by the same
token it's like I came to this movie sea
dragons put some dragons in it there's
only like for two or three scenes with
dragons
speaking of dragons I simply wanted to
get out of here bro he's dragging down
[Music]
babes are not my level I just when I see
any movement it's so dark I just shoot
immediately at them right I'm just
running out of ammo
you guys got to get these mines man
their minds are it's that's what it's
about
I need two topographical map oh I just
got some proximity mines oh [ __ ]
and it's ran into my own yeah so yeah so
yeah so you switch oh you switch your
weapon with never with over-they today
and then you roll out yeah these go oh
man it's so good but you can hurt
yourself - yeah
hey I got some lines guys I tried to
karate chop Aaron I'm really bleep
endless this is starting to feel like
freshman year
this gun is fun oh how come it alright
because I I'm ight have already set a
mine up there uh if you put two mines
together the bloke immediately she's not
somebody up there let me just shoot
first ask questions later
ah I killed myself hey plate that a mine
down oh good man alright
I think I might have cancer red claw
Yolo is what Game of Thrones fan jeez oh
jeez okay one minute left one minute
left for redemption just want it I won't
say caves is a bad idea
there's oh I ran into my own I'm just
glad we're going through this together
boys yeah really
ah gets good gags now I'm just running
into my own dumb I see suicide count
running into my own death mines it looks
hard how what how we rigged this uh we
got there's an adapter we bought that
that goes from RCA to HDMI right yeah
yeah who's it made back page well is it
oh 14 it's red mama we're going to Olive
Garden we'll be waiting on let me to
bread six mama am I just like I'm afraid
to move anywhere cuz I camera where I
put all the mines made by a tech city
etekcity and it fit in my crafters dream
yes yeah it's funny how the further
technology advances the harder it is to
my right back the classics alright well
that was um here we go oh here we go so
go to the go to the far left
oh it's dishonorable cuz I used mines
that's what I got
longest innings most asaro most
honorable shortest innings hey hey go to
the left go to those ma'am
oh wait that's you oh wait a little keep
going to the left oh wait
where's the armor most power weapon
choices unarmed
we do mine too yeah man I don't see how
that coming what what do you mean most
cowardly like I was going in there
without armor about whether they hit
start hit sir right I'm a man all right
you know what let's play something where
you can actually see each other yes okay
sunshine sunshine UV rays and UV what
about uh where should we play guys chat
where do you guys want to see us play
Oh Road Rash was a great game go
graduates fun yeah how's the library
lighting dude where's the i/o I feel
like library more what's up fix for
commissary soft lighting you know
impressive you gotta be able to read it
oh yeah oh yeah how does it feel bugs
how does it feel to be looking back on
what was cutting-edge technology
it still feels cutting-edge to me
because I'm not mastering it okay it's
depressing because I'm not mastered
lasers sure
let's try lasers our weight power well I
think power weapons includes lasers do I
do that power weapons is a good variety
it's do that good variety it's like the
Tour of Italy yeah
maybe well can we give you guys give you
guys more health whoa thanks more big
fan how much do I take that's I don't
know four or ten those are my own either
one need to go ten now will feel really
stupid when we die I'm gonna go for I'll
do no I think this is gonna be good I
think this is good you guys are gonna be
this is gonna be more than a hit a hit
yeah okay okay
all right here we go all right here we
go boys should get on one we're going
against the blue plugin we're the
Rooskies here we go here we go golden
gun only it ooh this is a crazy
I like the music's music right this is
almost music it oh they shot guy ready
that's not hair oh you want to talk
about a power weapon shotgun is a fun
weapon this music is awesome
[Music]
all right sure
I remember this this so I guess we can't
really talk about the new Spectre
trailer because yeah I've ruined
everything
it is I'll tell you that Spectre looks
like it could be the greatest bomb that
we evolved really that's how cool I know
who's in it can tell you who's in it
sure Daniel Craig and I love Craig Assad
by the way I love that he's a new brutal
bond and then Christoph Waltz is the bad
guy how's that armor working out for you
[Music]
power weapon my ass and shout you four
times
that's the hell are you that gun is Joe
yeah that's what row he killed me what
the first time he shoots super fast
thank you guys oh god okay I just got
the RC p90 whatever that thing is brutal
it's like it's clip is huge and you can
just hold it down it's like sprays
bullets oh well I got the magnet the
Magnum stove guys this music is awesome
I know music is great I'm gonna go for
run late the from I'm having is level is
how to get up and down stairs a comma
whole be done Magnum I know there's like
Y amps it's hard yeah well I'll jump
let's handicap of course pitch the 7 I
do like how wheelchair accessible these
maps are yeah I got 50 magnet bullets
I'm just gonna make some limited
breadsticks of death oh can I jump down
there you're gonna run down
[Music]
aiming is such a problem for me
Ami's Amy's becoming an issue Wow was
that you bleh
oh yeah light my ass up me my mother I
never why your ass over
for God's sakes shoot him just shoot him
gun please shoot him if I run at you in
a straight line I can shoot you just hit
him again one more time
cool come back though all he wanted to
do is bucks just running in a circle I
am running uh sorry I can't find how to
get upstairs hits Punisher by the way
great hey I do I even Punisher are you
excited about Jon Bernthal as The
Punisher oh so excited that's gonna be
guys got a darkness to him I think
that's yeah that's good he was great at
walking dead darkness again tattoos
wait I don't know we're talking about
this is all news to me mister I wonder
why I don't watch trailers that is the
whoa I don't know anything yet trailers
are our source of news yes exactly
Oh CNN trailer again I like hearing the
announcements I hate seeing the visual I
hate like did you watch Walking Dead do
you ever you know shame yes that's who's
the new partnership I can bear devil
yeah
so he's like in the Netflix series
daredevil nice found a dead guy
I think I'm getting gettin worsse it I'm
still running around in circles please
comment but I think I will go around in
oh wait a second
where's the RC p90 I got one we've all
got one that might not be good I mean
I've got one I don't know I know this
can I find somebody to shoot it at
that's a different story music is making
me crazy in my brain oh boy your sister
back in here yeah well they're the only
ones
she'll be back
nice to have another female that's right
what are you saying
Tracy yeah hey we'll we chopped liver Qi
we basement you guys I just got up here
so don't you dare go back downstairs I
was downstairs I'm trying to find a
staircase to go upstairs
I found the oh you son of a [ __ ]
right I'm clearly stuck on a different
floor oh look a hallway
hi guys
guys what's all the commotion
damn oh my god that health is crazy
I just unloaded a whole clip in your
face was like hitting you nope get him
get him oh my god now there's two of you
hot charges running don't reload now
this is this is the most business status
thing everyone anyone's ever seen might
get my at least making any contact I'm
making any contact you some contact
alright let's go chase this bastard not
shooting oh wait
I'm unarmed yeah I like it kill it kill
it kill him Wow
[Music]
for the love of God this is like the
worst
how are you not dead get out of the room
I'm out of here lift it but another day
oh we did armored up on this yeah
are we armored up yeah I feel like a rod
now it's like we're just kind on peds
and we're still just for good measure
don't your mom's not gonna debrief it
you're grounded
that's right you are grounded mister
going to Olive Garden mama my treat
a limited breadsticks a good I'm getting
I'm getting a try pasta thing where you
get like the the three think you guys
ever you are you develop early come on
we Maya read their Samaria kinds of post
is so much possible unlimited pasta
Jesus God
but what happens when I eat all the
pasta
come behind please kill this guy
[Music]
karate chopping it eventually if I can't
invite cheating your feet of Edgefield
bleed out without hitting you oh yeah I
think I was hitting it Wow
oh my god I'm help you know hop down get
a mind keep moving autopsy's Wiley that
little guy runs out yet scary yeah just
like comes flying at your side just
shooting everywhere he's like it has
many doubles pretty good attack by like
sleepy or dopey or somebody there you go
yeah well my first kill Oh waffles are
eventually the game default is shooting
the wall the spell things out yeah
that's basically what it is all right I
job I'm coming up to you all right
[Music]
so underground right now this really
should be in my headphones and I worked
out oh dude this kid this is like making
me crazy I feel like I got the punch
through a wall right now like it might
have to punch through a wall
yeah prove that I was actually in this
level that Brooks was here I promise
yeah that's the gold knob bloopers
hahahaha shotgun
[Music]
yeah well it was I played so much of
this game now I'm now I'm kind of using
I'm kind of using the left stick in the
right stick to kind of I'm here in the
basement
yeah strafe around corners we need to go
downstairs all right I've got one minute
run down power opens included like stuff
that blows up and maybe I was wrong
[Music]
next time I'm definitely doing laser I
want to see how these lasers work yeah I
want to go to the future come on arm
didn't own a Moonraker this yeah exactly
let me go to the moon most desirable
again most motors that's just
professional understandings my weapon of
choice we're no longer we've we made it
we made strides because my wife
notorious wasn't the karate chop
actually I've gone the RC p90 so try
grenade launcher best gun and game for
fun
oh all right let's try Rogers it's sorry
well it makes sense all the bad guys
have terrible aim at Bond movies I gotta
say man when I first saw the first
Daniel Craig movie I was blown away it
felt like it was such a reinvigoration
it needed it - after the last Pierce
Brosnan disaster which I love Goldeneye
yeah and tomorrow never dies okay but it
needed something fresh read agreed it
was like the Batman Begins of the bond
this is his last one writer right he's
got this one I think he's signed on for
one more oh sweet I hope so
yeah so people are saying like he's like
he killed it good happen I mean crazy
right whoa elodie great that would be
awesome
bond has a bond ever died on film uh I
think they killed Ozzie be right I don't
know they're gonna win
I have a the bond collection like the
whole all of these one VHS yeah I mean
it's an n64 okay here we go
feeling good this level is taking it
back got some amma and you get a gun
here real soon
we got the club like club sounds like a
bundle yeah and agree i love a club
sandwich I'm in collab thank you I'm
still looking for a gun clop sounds like
were you doing the bathroom after you
that's gotta go ticket club real quick
back gonna go drop club off at the pool
yeah I'm gonna say I'm gonna go on
record as saying I think I like Craig
might be my favorite bond is that crazy
he say I mean he's just rootaberger
generation he's handsome
that's right yeah but he's still pleased
about that but I also believe that he's
been drinking all those right right he's
not so good looking they like man this
guy how does this guy work out like you
can tell he's had a hard night out yeah
exactly but he still gets the babies
come on into this big room with no cover
who are you shooting at don't worry
about it okay
hi Blanc where are you worried I'm gonna
run and shoot oh man hey would you stand
still for oneself oh what's this a
grenade launcher okay there you go there
you go
Leigh you don't want to know he's got a
grenade launcher yeah but if I'm too
close to you your end user can you just
fill it with fire you got to you you got
to kill some monsters Hey look I found a
good night line the most obnoxious all
right we got some hashtag wet controller
alright I got to make my mama proud here
I used to throw that used to be my face
to throw my controller and I got mad
what are you at your control oh yeah I
have some crazy badass rifle that zooms
I don't understand I don't understand
people who throw their phone when
they're angry it's like it's your phone
you're just pretty it used to be a lot
easier when this phone had a cord
attached to it yeah here you go find it
now kid oh I don't know I see a lot of
fire I got it oh you have my grenade oh
yeah well I have a grenade I don't see
your name on it it's a grenade launcher
we're a family and we share weapon blaze
trying to flank well I'm not gonna run
into a room that's filled with fire
you're the one guy that read the art of
war
- yeah for this mission guys kill is a
kill
I just myself down in the process lunar
assassin said I've never thrown in
controls I've never been that mad and it
follows it up with I haven't hit someone
with way worse by the way wayward
stitches like yeah like what are you
doing just throw it at that point crazy
Oh looks like somebody sustained on the
wall don't somebody took a club in here
guys
they clogged all over this place who
what superhero is that somebody answer
who said it's clobberin time is that
book oh so when he says it's clobberin
time he's just going to the bed excusing
himself uh-huh and he goes like this
he's like everybody out there watching
this next time you got to go rocket
deuce excuse yourself and say it's
clobberin time I don't know if I've
killed a single person we've killed you
and that's I know you guys are that's
grenade launchers is your chance but
always remember boo yeah let's don't go
through fire what is this it's clobberin
time spider much shut up spank you man
pants you know we're talking about Ross
Thank You Mick pants I won't stand for
that Spanky big pants yeah stop with the
superhero crossover laughing exactly
famous catchphrases they'll take famous
credit races for $400 which I'm still
kind of a fan of by the way I like the
fact that movies are you can combine
universes you can have all these
superheroes yeah please I think it's
pretty sweet that is awesome
I am definitely into that I don't want
another Spiderman origin story I just
want to see him hang out with talk about
why we need an origin for everything I
don't know yeah I mean I think that
we're getting away from that which is
nice it's like Oh remember how my
parents died and that fits like I don't
care about your stupid parents Bruce
come on somebody there's a job there's
there's about the pan over and I had the
rocket one most cowardly
lane I can't wait to see what lies
professional double kick
killed today's award Wow double kill
nice job I got the lemming award which
in blood which in golden eyes like the
certificate of participation it means
yeah you showed up I used to hide in
broken crates this odd job oh you can
crouch and disappear good job I'll play
this making me pants we're not good
enough in this game yeah yeah yeah what
did she tell me how I can cheat more
first you got to know the controls yeah
if you like how do I throw my hat
somebody tell me cuz I know that's a
thing right I don't know how to do it
and if it's a cheat I'll do it tightly
and 64 was like the Golden Age of cheat
codes though do you guys remember game
genie oh yeah super Barbara's you could
jump over the tower and keep running
that Lisa always what was on the other
side of the castle nothing it was a
great metaphor for life if you reach too
high for your dreams you've ended up
being by yourself I'm sorry hit hit yeah
alright here we go alright what we're
going water caverns lasers water so
we're taking the handicap suit yeah
we're too proud of our yeah yeah do you
you do everybody for themselves sure
you're not ready for that right now you
know we should do it before before we
leave just a reminder what is the worst
yeah
thanks we already know yeah I was
getting new goalie gun Joe rocks I'm
seeing 10/2 tonight big head mode oh
yeah we saw what's coming up what are
what are so much twos on tap I'm seeing
minions and Ted to later today's you do
you go in with expectations you try not
to I try not to but it's but sometimes
when you're reviewing a movie you
realize the expectations are out there
right so you want to let them know hey I
was disappointed it's still okay but
like if Star Wars is a four and a half
out of five shows as opposed to five out
of five smooth yeah I'll be a little
disappointing so I went in with high
exposure yeah that's true Oh oh goodness
this level is very I'm stuck in a
hallway I'm out of bullets
oh my god get me out of here I'm wrong I
remember this level this little you know
what you don't realize it's so hard to
kill odd-job because I'm not good anyway
and he's got he's got increased health
yeah well so do you
yeah I know I don't have a green baby
look for guys named team I ran right
past you for Blair yeah I forgot I'm
certain I saw you and I was just going
for that cheap kill shot that's gonna
get me most cowardly but you know what I
don't play the game for awards I play
the game for kills and embarrass mom
there we go thanks God die I jump you
little bastard doesn't body armor where
are the sons doesn't all the fun without
me
man you're so quick wily just ran right
past me like I'm gonna say this water
caverns is the most bond like set
looking pieces there is I feel like
there's gonna be sharks with lasers I
hate this map
Sydney I'll shoot me reverb city's
behind me I expect you to die
I expect me to die also so there you go
your your black suit is making you very
hard to find yeah my white suit is I
feel like making me a target in every
level there's no snow level I have a
getting fried fish destroy right now I
need a better gun somebody dies I can
take your gun yeah that's a great idea
can I have your gun please you can get
the gun off better Lyons TV yes we will
be streaming I'm sure Battlefront Star
Wars my character appears to be fro
here's to be stuck in some sort of
existential hell raised to fight you
that have gotten me so excited about
that Star Wars game that I'm gonna run
out and get a piece yeah I'm gonna steal
my brother's gonna come down I'm so wait
and it's so exactly my kind of game is
and it's Star Wars like I have a problem
I'm gonna I'm never gonna leave that
house I also got to play some no man's
sky which is amazing that game is gonna
be super fun I'm unloading my clip
seriously our man I reload by the way
there we go green I was I was [ __ ] I
always stuck up against glass I believe
give me a laser man where the lasers
that where my lasers at these are that
all the ways is in the house say oh you
know I would like to say how because I
would love to have a laser can't go up
in this okay I got 99 guns in a ways or
anyone yes sirree and I would like all
my guns to be lasers I'd like to have 99
lasers yeah yeah ways it'd be fun where
is the laser come on walk to the store
there's no waves in the water dad I see
you on job
get out here buddy okay
I'm out here now that you guys have
better health it's hard to kill you
am I even touching you running away I'm
out of here
hey Amani I'm back Lena job hey no I'm
out of here back most cowardly one
minute left one minute oh wow I can't
believe what is happening I just get
very cocky by the way I got that we got
the new waterwheel where is it
go ahead to drop his controller I think
it's underneath by the water through the
tunnel shame I got it okay you got the
laser I got the laser not just oh jesus
oh my god shoot up nervous oh I just I
wanna see our job just get destroyed by
oh yeah that's a bit that's a very 70s
laser yeah exactly
Oh somebody screw you a little man die
come on I'm daddy's catchphrase no kills
that was arresting this guy I was I was
mostly harmless I think I got clobbered
first now that maps suck that master
alright let's play Golden Gun you gotta
play Golden Gun which one Golden Gun is
one shot one kill or sad yeah yeah yeah
golden gonna let's lend a temple that's
a fun easy thing I see that's bright
familiar with the temple - yeah I think
we like play a home court game wait wait
scenario whoops whoops there you go here
we go man with the Golden Gun should I
not be so because I'm cheating or should
I just let it run fine with it okay
sameer legal gun is there's only one
golden gun and everyone else tries to
kill them when they have the gold yeah
when they have the going gun you go for
the guy who killed me oh my god it's
like king of the hill I can't wait
moving he'll exactly Camus yeah looking
at human him like a human hill here we
go play what's your favorite game you
played at e3 oh I mean no man Scott was
awesome
starts now froze awesome there's a lot
of really cool indie games there's one
that was like black and white that I
loved where it's like a multiplayer game
where you're all black are all white and
you can hi and so is the world and so
you can hide in your own color that's
pretty cool really fun what do we got
coming up on the sports game front uh
sports game I didn't play any sports
games but there is any new improvements
on mad and white can you I want sure can
you actually be the GM of a team if
you're really good at it this year yeah
I played mirrored the new Mirror's Edge
looks awesome I wish you would die died
alright sorry mom I gotta kill a guy yo
alright
this map is all about rocket launchers
we're playing old ladies I just got a
kill come on over to my post two minutes
your life because guys seriously to
Olive Garden people if you're watching I
want that a limited pasta path I got one
last year oh you bet sweet and they
supported maze a lot of dates with a lot
of girls now I have a girl uh - see
that's what that's what I'm gonna get a
girl good job through the pasta pot yeah
I used to be friends
remember that is still time to fix this
just look at how the Golden Gun you guys
could fight amongst yourselves um yeah
we're gonna turn on baby pool cuphead
looks amazing it's like I heard about
that cup head it's like it looks like an
old 30s cartoon you want gigantic looks
good
cuphead is basically the game that
attacks adaptation Steamboat Willie
evolved yeah yeah yeah
fallout 4 of his amazing fallout 3 is
old my favorite games of all time so I'm
really looking for
right trying to walk over
there we go there's my Soviet there's my
body
[Music]
you looking for the gun sorry I can't
let you sorry son
I gotta see some ID to be in here auto
aim off oh god no odd jobs in here
getting up court gotta get forward to
get out straight my only hope is
fighting the Golden Gun where's it at
there's what do you got you guys have
the gun probably have it don't know
this is a room of death right now
otherwise known as my bedroom what's up
cuz there's no life
take that pasta boy
my search
when I find it everybody's in big big
trouble
run away
I've completely stopped aiming oh really
yeah I'm just all Auto and I'm just
going general I just put a whole clip
and it didn't work
oh there we go that make some kills I'm
playing really well here putting in a
little bit of new ways trying to
convince I just need a 90 minute warm-up
a silence pp7
anyone in the chat know where the Golden
Gun is yeah we got to get down you got
to find the ACE man going down
come on down I'm going down it whatever
boys your stairs leading pump I'm going
down somewhere
oh no I'm just then like a little this
music is awesome to whoever made whoever
made this on the map bottom floor to you
right up go the bullets golden boy oh
yeah bullets go the bullets I don't like
the idea of Aaron with a golden gun I'm
Adam bullets
just looking for some friends or do we
all have the Golden Gun there's nothing
going on about any of my performance
though now it's on now it's on baby did
you get it you now it's on
where you at our job it's you son of a
[ __ ] you little mother oh come on no no
no no get him now
now a short guy with body on now we got
a problem and we might have to team up
oh definitely team it up hey boys you're
on for pasta Pat's back buddy
I'll be the marinara sauce to your
breadsticks X what it wasn't we're just
what easily is it's make it bleed dude
this is good she's not even a Golden Gun
it's more like a pee yellow gun yeah
all right they're only there's only one
golden gun I think right fellas fellas
he's got it the noise and everything
then get more help still guys I'm
perched and I'm all right
great sex 97 yeah I don't know how to
open doors
[Music]
guys notice my gun
oh man I don't know I got your back
pasta packs Oh Oh nope saisiyat you
sorry I'm out of golden gun bolt down
there he's down there got a boat's a
horrible it's horrible he got a lot of
bullets Oh chirping running get him
Aaron I'm getting there
ah you little fella Serge come here
Aaron if I see you by accident just that
we're pasta buddies for life
come on come on come on come on come on
Clyde endure in the door okay you come
here this moves oh that's that's you hit
the green button it goes whatever open
damn it
gave you a gun again
yes all right man we put a lot of let
into that dude so much lit all right
wait
pasta facts over though you have the
golden gun no I don't have any golden
gun the bullets there was no bullets oh
yeah let's do it baby
I held the golden gun back we're back do
you have golden gun bullets do I have
golden gun bullets yeah baby 22 come on
and play all right Oh
mantastic oh yeah 20 bullets left
devastating oh good I got a silenced bp7
so I can't hear what I'm opening me I'm
opening a new website death for gold doc
nam yo treating yourself lob that gun
has gone to your head you're not the guy
used to know I got a club
it's bastard come here
bullets oh yeah our just fun killing odd
job cuz I hate that I hate it it seems
like he gets shorter with every pass Oh
uglier every time I just collected all
the weapons and I left the last time I
died there's just it's just littered
with going I'm so sure so short I can't
see him I'm not gonna put my shoe on my
head Spanky why would we Pyrrha
coordinates good most deadly oh I got
most cowardly honorable I guess most
dishonorable yes all right you got one
more game in us guys what are we gonna
play we're game one more game this is it
this is for all the marbles everything
up to now has been practiced for Golden
Gun what do you wanna play well what's
our most what's our phase pretty fun
that's pulling guns pretty awesome yeah
dude be like temple do we like something
smaller uh smaller let's you know what
we haven't done the library a library
let's do it it's do library lighting
how's the light man with the Golden Gun
sure never going gun all right let's do
it
slappers somebody say there's fights for
some argue arguments for slappers
wait what's license to kill that might
just be one one shot one death license
to kill is that what misses are killers
Oh everybody has one shot one kill
yeah or is that like golden guns for
everybody yeah golden guns all around
baby come guns all around that'll be
frustrating let's do it we could
barbecue here we go yeah everything is
going up so sorry sorry I'm done with go
back go back now you can you can choose
the same guy I
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do a different
deal Waco jaws or is he gonna be slow do
they move like the characters I'm gonna
be using Indiana jaws is hard I think
because she's cute well hey bro don't
faint that's I'm sticking with a job I'm
going SS I'm gonna be Xenia because
she's almost a warrior princess he's
awesome and what do we want what guns I
like the power gun I like the power guns
one pyro you're sure pistol slappers
might be fun
slappers white has it has a license to
kill yes to kill one slap you're dead is
that okay the crazier things have
happened
let's it look like we'll play a quick
five there's me the second to last game
cuz if this sucks we don't want this to
be our eyes game all right
is that this is gonna be more of a slap
result lappers only slappers my favorite
company cut slappers this see well
Seanie is well and dad okay and running
around here we go
fighting armor not gonna help me
this music is kind of like it's a
slappers music I was actually expecting
slappers music could be like go like a
Benny the bastard can get upstairs
ah so sure haha alright
how could this have been a mistake this
is great this is like every flight that
breaks out yeah PA you son of a-- that's
right now was it one slap it's laughable
slap it's just what you had the target
on I did but I don't know if you need to
do that you're just so short I just kept
going like right over my hand slap the
crotch oh nana license to kill power
weapons language keeps the Taser I think
you fell on me I'm done I died any
little any little tab
yeah just Julia in this game just like
me in real life
yeah this is a metaphor for life guys
that way soak up our message yes yeah
we're gay baby
we're just joining us with Mark Ellis
from Stroh's no youtube.com slash
suppose suppose now right Roby
Hershkovitz from our own show hello we
teamed up for a little while he was in
schmoeville for a minute that's what I'm
up against there and in his olive garden
pasta friends chasing me I've been
chasing you for a while breaks the
flower pot get it that's right kids
always employed Top Gun techniques Simon
see Joe Simon cello what does that mean
game sexual video games that's probably
correct that's happened before Lara
Croft Tomb Raider you kidding me hailey
smackeroos you little punk the old
one-two / there like an uppercut I can
like you've miss him he's yeah you
downer cut yeah you're right I need like
a downer cut when every time I get a
haircut it's a downer wasn't super at
all yeah I don't go to Fantastic Sams I
just go to ok Sam's late but so far it's
only me and blade yeah we're you LS I
have no idea where most cowardly that's
right you guys that's very slapping
something else around wait a minute yeah
I hope you guys don't walk in on me
using my hand it's like that you know
what I'm getting down to your level
here we go now it's on yeah yeah crotch
I know you fell on me I think you guys
are both dead is to say yeah it's just a
twister not that I'm running over all
right I've coming to find you
ridiculous glare let's get him is that
made come over here oh I'm looking at
ceiling I'm on your level now I Jeff I
know ah so you fall on me I think I
slapped you you're going down you're
like it's like you guys punch each other
at the same time yeah it's like the end
of rocky - it's like meanwhile I'm just
doing cross it over here by myself
yeah good lord what's going on over
there all right we're gonna do one more
game after this it's gonna be that was a
good chicken fight that wasn't good
did you kill or be killed at all I
killed you once oh that's right I killed
you once but I'm definitely gonna get
most cowardly weapon of choice we're all
on arms no strike granting most
professional oh very nice mostly
harmless all right here we go all right
last week license to kill power web
places to kill power well let's do it
it's time here we go all right here we
go this is for all the pasta hit start
yeah I'm top left I am top right bottom
left here we go license to kill power
weapons library let's go
complex let's go people were saying cop
yeah yeah complex or complex graphics
we're doing that here we go alright is
this for all the pasta Jets here we go
who's gonna win who's gonna take a big
fat slob pasta match who's gonna take a
big fat
okay we got that so we got a real fun
gun here or Jesus I have armor I've ammo
and I'm no good I like those odds
come on always a gun by the ammo ah yeah
job oh yeah I want to just talk to you
for a second Oh slapping no no no no no
no Jesus no way I just come on walk on
into the room walk under there and see
it happen where did you go bleh ah scary
well that was one case where you point
one shot one kill yeah yeah oh man what
oh my god auto-aim do something do
something oh good lord
hahaha troller just hates shooting you I
think oh it's like an automatic right Oh
our seep here we go here we go now we're
gonna have a little fun alright so we're
playing one shot one kill technically a
slap could it's like having like a
squirt gun with bullets it seemed so
personal with you boy I don't know where
are you you're there damn it
I have no mother oh you can walk through
events there is one hidden vent in this
I did yeah and then I didn't have a way
I have no gun so that it's not
necessarily gonna hurt you I mean you
have your hands well you have fists of
Steel walk into this room of death this
is okay just do it which is incidentally
what they do say when you go to the
Olive Garden but we're just kidding
enjoy the fun
ah oh yeah you're killed an unarmed man
well you know what you've killed me with
no arms and that came out bad you know
what I'm saying
I wish I could kill with the walks boys
but I could just man okay I just have a
weapon got a weapon
now it's huntin time did I get a gun Oh
90 pistola tiny pistola for a tiny man
what I need is I just haven't had passed
in so long up somebody's death blossom I
spin it fire aah aah
somebody hit me damn it
I had him in my sights
you only takes one bullet only takes one
bullet here we go this one that'll do
real nice guys all this Olive Garden
talkin seriously got oh Jesus God yes
yes yes take that I hope you feel bad I
hope you feel bad about yourself just go
I go straight for the emotion just so
bad you're a terrible human being just
like why do i do eat that's awful what I
see that's somebody body armor is not
helpful and I have no gun oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no yes yes yes
yes yes I can see the bullets like
popping all around as a little
snowflakes snowflakes the ban is getting
really tired of playing that there there
yeah exactly
oh no I got bullets can I just throw
bullets and somebody lose that one
minute what is that that's it's almost
about 10 seconds oh God probably where's
the ammo but RCP one two ID or p90 I had
the RC p90 but where's the ammo Kyra
Lackey
okay well thank you for join us for
Monday melee thanks to Mark Ellis from
Smosh no go to youtube.com slash Moe's
now and Twitter all eyes are the best
hit us up on Twitter I suppose though
hit me up on Twitter at 5150 Ellis and
let me know just how awful I am
bring it out I'd love to come back
voiceless yeah Talos AUSA's play some
tech those two missiles if we can hook
up an n64 this we can hook up a gameboy
to this nice and it's on dude yeah we'll
figure out the Gameboy situation you
have to glue gents are great thank you
very much thank you to Roey
thanks to Beth and Jason O'Malley thank
you guys for joining us for Monday
Bailey we'll see you guys next week